React router is extremely
common to use in React projects.
John Smith yoga has created many popular courses.
And now he will teach you about React router.
What's up everybody? This is John from coding.
And welcome to React Router six tutorial video.
Now, if you're not familiar with React Router,
it's an awesome library that mentioned building
single page applications with React a breeze. So
unlike the traditional multi page applications,
where we run back to the server
every time we navigate to the page
with single page applications, we load all of our
HTML and JavaScript in one page, more specifically
in one div, and handle the rest of the logic
with the help of JavaScript. And as a result, our
project get that snappy app light feel. Now, since
react does not have built in routing solutions,
that's why we reach for extra library. And
by far, the most popular option out there
is React router. And version six is
just the latest and greatest option
with a bunch of cool new features and custom
hooks. So if we take a look at the typical multi
page application, we'll notice that every time we
navigate to a page, we trigger full page refresh,
because browser needs to run back to the
server, get a competence and display them.
Unlike the React application, where changes happen
instantly. Notice, get this snappy response. And
the reason for that is because we have single page
application. So like I said, we have single page.
More specifically, we have a single div with an
id of root. And then all the changes then handled
by JavaScript, and therefore the contents of
the page, load instantly without the full page
refresh. In order to follow along, you'll need a
star and it's located in this repo. So look for
my GitHub, and then more specifically
the repo by the name of React Router,
six tutorial, then I'm going to go for download
option. After that, navigate my downloads,
crack it open, drag and drop. So now it's sitting
on my desktop, then I think I'll rename it,
I'm just gonna go with React Router, how's that I
want to open up Visual Studio Code, drag and drop,
set right away, side by side with a browser. And
LAN, we want to open up the integrated terminal.
And we want to go with npm install, and right away
npm start. And essentially, this is a boilerplate
react application. Effectively I created with
create react app. And in here, you'll just find
some useful resources. So we don't have to type
out some boilerplate code. So in the source,
there's a final folder, where you'll find
complete application. So if you ever need to
reference the code that I type in the videos, you
can find it over there. We also have Pages folder.
You'll see in the following videos, why
we haven't there effectively is just
a bunch of React components. And again, we'll talk
about them in future videos. After that, we have
app Jas, where we just have a heading to with this
text, data j is also something that will implement
all with later index CSS with all of the styling.
Now there's not much to it. But still, I added
a little bit of styling here. And of course index
Jas. And also in the route, you'll find readme,
where I wrote down all the steps we're going to
take throughout this project. And if you see in
the browser, react, router, six tutorial, then
we're in good shape. And we can start exploring
React Router six. Okay, before we start typing
away, let me just mention a few things. First,
if you ever want to run the complete application,
so not just reference the code in the final one,
but if you actually want to see some feature
in action, just go to index j s, and swap the
app js files. So essentially, you want to get the
objects from the final folder. So like I said,
final folder is where you find complete
application. And in here, there's also a
app J Yes, so just go to index Jas, get the app
js from the final folder. And I already added
the code, you just need to comment the first one
out on common the last one, that if you ever need
a reference to official documentation, I left it
in a readme a link. So if you click on this link,
you will navigate to the official docs off React
Router, six. And when it comes to install for
yarn projects, the command you're looking for
is NPM, install react, router DOM at six. Now,
of course, I already installed this package in
this project, but just so you don't think that
there's some funny business going on.
With me, open up here of the terminal,
I'll clear everything, I'll run the command. Once
the install is complete, and the package json,
we'll see or React Router DOM package. And as
far as the setup, here's what we want to do.
We want to go to app J S. And let me start this
up. So npm start, we want to import three things,
we want to get the browser router, which is
going to connect to the actual browser, the
routes component, which is going to be a parent
for all our routes, and then route component,
which we'll use to set up a single page. So let's
go there. Let's start setting up the code. And
then I'll talk about the props and rest of the
stuff. So let me first navigate to app J S,
like I said, we want to grab three components.
Now eventually, we'll also get a link
and some other ones as well. But for now,
these are the ones that we want. So browser,
router, routes, and a route. And as a quick
side note, if you want, you can add browser
router in the index js, basically where you wrap
the whole application, but in my case, I'll settle
for app. Jas, then we want to go with React,
and then router DOM. Like I said, first,
we want to connect to the actual browser. So
we'll go with browser router, we'll set up
the route component. So let's go here with routes.
And then we need to set up those single routes.
And basically the idea is following where we go
with route, then we need to go with path. So this
is going to reflect whatever we have in the URL.
And when it comes to the homepage, we have special
syntax where we go forward slash now in this local
setup, that forward slash means localhost 3000. In
production, that is going to be whatever is your
domain, whether that is udemy.com, or youtube.com,
or John smell, good outcome. And hopefully you
see where I'm going with this. So this is special,
this forward slash, but basically, where we have
the path will set up whatever URL is going to be
here in the URL bar. So for example, if I want
to have a page by the name of best thing, then
instead of forward slash, I'll type path equals
to testing. And if I want to set up a nested one,
let's say I want to go with products, and then
forward slash INFO, then yes, you guessed it,
one of the ways we can set it up is going with
products here, and then forward slash testing. And
if you're a little bit iffy on that, don't worry.
As we cover more examples, it's going to be easier
to understand that. So first, let's go with path
forward slash, again, path means our homepage, and
then we want to go with element at the very basic
level, we can just pass in the code directly here
in the element. And in the upcoming videos, we'll
see how we can use components for that. But at
the very basic level, we just need to set up here
what we want to see on the screen. So in my case,
I'm gonna go with a simple div here. And I'll say,
homepage, like so. So let me close out the route
component. And once we save, we should see on page
unreal. So that is my home page. And like I said,
Now let's set up some dummy page. And I'll call
this testing. So instead of forward slash, which
is a syntax for the homepage, and simply go here
with testing. Now, if I'm going to write about,
then, of course, in the URL, I'll have to type
forward slash about. Now if I have testing,
and you guessed it, I'll go with forward slash
testing. And when I want to display here, well,
let's make this one a little bit more complex
just to showcase that of course, we can set up
whatever logic we want over here. So I'm gonna go
with Dave and then inside of it We're going to go
with heading two, and then the testing. Let's save
it. And eventually, of course, there's going to
be a navbar, and all that good stuff. But for
now, yes, we'll have to do all the navigation
in the URL bar. So let me navigate there. And
what is the page name? Well, it is best thing
correct. So we go forward slash, and manifesting.
Once we navigate there, check it out. Now we
have our page. And if we want to go back to the
homepage, you guessed it, we just need to go back
to the localhost 3000. So again, we install the
package, we grab three components, browser router,
routes, and route browser, our connect to
the browser route is going to be a parent
for all our routes. And then for every page,
we'll set up a route component with two props,
a path. So what is going to be the URL. And what
we want to render, we pass into the element about
about and we created our first pages, life is
great. But you would have to agree with me that
when it comes to any realistic application,
hard coding, the page content in app js, is
probably not going to be very good on your health,
you'll just end up screaming at your computer.
So here's the thing, we can also pass in component
directly. So path setup stays the same. Again,
whatever we type over here, will match in the URL
bar. So if it's forward slash than its own page,
if it's about, hopefully you see where I'm
going with this. But when it comes to element,
we can pass here the component, and therefore,
you'll find in the pages a bunch of components.
Again, the only reason why I set them up
is just so we can save a little bit of time
on setting up the boilerplate. So for the most
components, it will just find this section with
the class name of section. So in here, we just
add a little bit of CSS, you can take a look
at it in the index, CSS, and heading to with
about. So these are the pages that we will have
in our project. So here's what I want to do. I
want to go to app. Jas, I want to import them all.
So for now, just home about product. Notice
all of them are coming from the pages. And as,
of course, you don't have to name
your folder pages. It can be anything,
it can be banana pudding. Also, there's nothing
special about these components. They're straight
up components. The only difference is that now we
will use them in the app js. And we'll pass them
into the element prop. And as a result,
whatever we have in the component, we'll
be the content of the page. And yes, in those
components, you can import another component,
which also is something we're going to do. And
as you can see, as a result, it's going to be
easier to manage your application instead of hard
coding everything in the app J S. So let's try
this one out where I want to go to app J S. And
I want to import three components. And lastly,
if you want to set up here, index j s, that
is your preference. Or basically in the pages,
you import all of the components and then
export them, you can also do so. But in my case,
I'll just go the long route where I'll say
import, then home. Now when it's coming from,
now I'm looking for the Pages folder, and more
specifically home one, let me copy and paste here.
Let me just change a few things around where I
want to go with a about one. So let me select
that one. And we also want to go with the product.
So let's go here. And let's say product. Once we
have all of the imports in place. Now let's keep
the path forward slash again, this is going to
be for the homepage. But let's change it around
for testing one where I will remove it first.
And I'll actually pass here the home component.
Let's close it. That's also unnecessary.
And check it out. Now we have that too. Let's copy
and paste and let's just change the round where
it's going to be about this one will be
product and when it comes to path in here we'll
say about as well as product. And again, we're
gonna test that out if we navigate to URL.
And then if we go with forward slash about,
check it out and then we have about page Now,
you can probably already guess that if I'm
going to go to product will navigate to
the product page. So that's how we can set
up our page content. As components. Again,
we set up most likely a folder, since there's
going to be multiple pages. And we're just set up
straight up components. There's nothing special
about them. They're straight up components. The
only one that has more info in here is the login
one. But we'll talk about this one a little bit
later. Once we actually get there. Whatever you
set up over here, whether that's a bunch of other
components coming from other folders, and all that
will be the content of the page. And as a result,
it's easier to manage your entire application.
Alright, next, let's take a look at how we can
navigate around our project. Because at the
moment, the only way how we can do that using URL
bar, not as probably not the best user experience,
unlike the traditional multi page application
where we use the href, the link element, in this
case, if we want to navigate around our project.
So internally, we want to grab the link component
from React Router DOM. Now, if we want to go
somewhere externally, for example, if I want to
go to google.com, or John's milk.com, then yes,
you still need to use the link component like so.
So you'll set up a link component h ref, and then
whatever the URL. But in order to navigate around
our project, we'll use the link component instead.
And then blink and bone and is looking for
one thing, swung for to prop. And then notice,
we just pass in the URL. Now again, we don't need
to go with full URL in here, we just need to go
with forward slash and then whatever we have
in the app J S. So since I have these pages,
forward slash, so the homepage about and product
kind of makes sense. In the homepage, if I want
to go to About page, I need to go with forward
slash and then the name is about Now these ones
do need to match. So make sure that the syntax is
correct. So in home, Jess, I want to set up a link
to about just right after the heading two. And
then in the about Jess, I want to send back the
link to the homepage. So let me try this one out.
Where first I guess I'm gonna go to the homepage.
So with me navigate through the pages, then
we're looking for home. Jas, when we want to get
the link one. So import, it's a named imports a
link from React Router DOM. And then right after
the home page, let's go with link to and again,
I want to navigate to your product, we're gonna
go with forward slash product. Now if I want to go
to about I'm gonna go to forward slash and about,
and let's add name. So whatever we want to
display here, and a little bit of styling,
therefore I'm gonna go with class name. I'm just
gonna say BTN. So once we save, notice, now I have
this link to the about page. Now we navigate
to about without that full page refresh. And in
order to make this a little bit more interesting,
why don't we also do the same thing in the about,
so then we will be able to go from one
to another one. So let's go to about Jas.
Same deal, want to grab the link, import, and
link probably should have copied and pasted.
But anyway, so React Router DOM right after the
heading two, let's go with link two. In this case,
I want to go back to the homepage, say back
home. Online. Let's also add that class name,
a little bit of styling class BTN. So now we can
nicely go from page to page without that full
page refresh. Again, if we want to navigate around
our project, we want to grab the link component,
it's looking for one thing and one thing only
looking for to prop. And in here, you want to
pass in the same value that you already have here
as far as the path. So if you want to go to about
you go forward slash about. And if you want to go
to product, you go to forward slash products and
hopefully you see where I'm going with this.
Okay, but what if by mistake, the user types,
some kind of path that doesn't exist. So
let's say I'm gonna go with forward slash,
and then hello. The moment basically will display
nothing. Why? Well, because if we take a look at
our app js were only unlink these routes, we have
Ford slash home and about products. And in order
to handle this type of scenario, we want to set
up an error page, where essentially will display
some kind of error message for every request
that doesn't match any of our routes.
And we want to do that with a route component,
we want to pass in the path with a star. So
essentially, this will match everything.
So if we can't find those pages over here,
then this will collect all of them. And then we
want to set up some kind of error page. So first,
let's set up this in the app J S. And then we'll
work on the error page. Now there is already
a page in the pages. But I just want to add a
little bit more content. So first, let's go to
app. Jas. Let's copy and paste. And yes, we
want to place here all the way at the end,
because this catches pretty much everything. So we
want to go here with the star. And now let's work
on the error page. Or essentially at the
moment, again, we have this section with a
class of section I'm heading to with an error. But
I want to set up a link back home. And I said this
is what we're going to be working on. So we want
to get the link component from React Router Dom,
we want to add some kind of logic. So 404
Page not found. And then we want to navigate
back home. So let's try this one out where in
this case, I'll speed this up, I'll grab the link,
since will mean that one, then after the heading
two, or you know what, let's change this one
around, we're gonna go 404. So Page Not Found
a paragraph page found. And then we want to go
with link component to where I want to navigate,
well, I want to go back home. And in this case,
let's just say back home, let's save this, we
want to import a new page. So let's try out the
auto import. So I'm gonna go here with error.
And let's see whether I got actually the page
now it doesn't look like it. So let's try one
more time. Yep, over here, I can use the auto
import. And notice now we have a nice 404 page. So
if I'm gonna go with forward slash, and testing,
same deal with don't have that particular page in
our project. So basically, there is no URL that
matches that, and therefore we display this
error page. Now, if we click on Back home,
we naturally navigate back home. Alright, next,
let's see how we can add navbar and footer to our
project. Now in this video, I'll quickly show
you the most basic approach, which clearly has
its limitations, since it adds the same components
or elements to all of the pages. But don't worry,
in the following videos, we're also going to cover
more fine grained approach, where we will nest our
pages and set up the shared layout. As far as the
basic setup, we simply want to set up the elements
above or below the URLs. Again, please don't make
the mistake and place the elements inside of it,
you will get an error. But if you place it
above or below the routes, this will be added
to all of the routes, like I said, most basic
approach. But there's definitely situations
where this is a nice solution. So let's navigate
back, we're going to go above the routes,
we're going to set up the nav component,
basically an element. And yes, of course,
you can set up the component import it here. And
also, of course, you can add the links. Now I'm
not going to add the links in this scenario, since
we're going to do that in the upcoming examples.
And I don't want to repeat myself and waste your
time. Basically, I'll go here with our app bar.
The same thing we can do with footer, I'll say
our footer. And once you save, you'll notice that
in all of the pages have the number as well
as the footer, if we navigate your route,
same is going to work with products. And it's not
going to be surprised if we navigate to another
page. And we get the same result number and four
gets added to all of the pages. So this is the
most basic approach, how we can set up some shared
layout, where essentially in this case, we're
adding both of these elements to all of our pages.
Alright, next let's add a navbar to our project.
And in the process, we'll learn how to set up
mess the drought shared layout index page. Since
I want to cover everything step by step, please be
prepared. to refactor our application few times.
So if I want to nest some routes inside
of the another route, I just need to
go with the parent route. So notice, instead of
self closing the home one, I'm going to go with
an opening tag and the closing tag. And then I
just decide which routes I want to set up in here.
There's going to be multiple issues with our
original setup, the main focus is that now, all
of these routes will be nested inside of the home
one. Basically, they will be relative to whatever
we have as a path to a home road. And don't
worry, I'll show you also with another example,
just so you can see better again, we'll refactor
our application multiple time, so don't worry
if in the beginning, some stuff break. So
let's navigate back to app. Jas, like I said,
I want to nest about product and the error page
inside of the home one, because I do want to
set up a shared layout. And I want to set
up also a navbar. So let's try this out,
where instead of self closing, let's go here,
let's say route, and then close it. And,
of course, there's a syntax error like so. Like
I said, there's going to be multiple issues,
if I go to about, I'll actually see the homepage.
And yes, that is something we're going to fix in
a few videos. Now the main idea right now
is the fact that these are all relative
to the homepage. And it's kind of hard to see,
since this is homepage, since we're doing the
setup on homepage. So therefore, let me showcase
that if I'm gonna go here with dashboard instead.
Right now, you'll notice that you won't be able
to navigate to an about page, you'll have to go
to a dashboard, forward slash vote. So that's the
key about nesting routes, where whatever you have
here as a parent will be the main route. And
then whatever is inside is going to be forward
slash and whatever path is over here. So let me
save it notice, we cannot see anything. But if we
go to dashboard, which is technically our home
run right now, and then about when everything
technically works. Now, we still don't display
the about one, but we'll fix that in a second.
So hopefully this is clear. Where are they in our
case, we are using as a parent, our home one. But
for example, if I'm going to go outside of this
home one, if I'm just gonna say okay, let me set
up the dashboard, you'll see how basically this
works again, you won't be able to see actually,
what is displayed in the stats, for example, the
page that I'm about to set up, but you will be
able to see that this is how it works. So element.
And let me go quickly with them over here,
I'll say, dashboard. So and then we want to match
this. So let me go here with the route. And then
inside of it, we'll set a path, and then whatever
path I want. So in my case, I'm gonna go with
stat. So now we're looking for dashboard, and
then stats. So this is how we normally will nest
routes. And again, we won't be able to see
this stat there. Because we need to add
a little bit more logic, which we'll do
in the next video. This is just showcase
how this nesting is going to work. If we're going
to go to a dashboard and stat. Now you'll see
that we'll have this dashboard one, but the route
exists. So technically, there are no issues over
there. Now if I go to dashboard, this is where
I'm displayed. And now if I go to about again,
since our parent over here is the home route,
that's why we see the about page again, that's the
first step how we can nest routes inside of the
parent route. And then whatever we have for a path
is going to be the main path. Whatever we
set up over here is going to be the parent
plus this value over here. So if you go here
with dashboard, then it's going to be dashboard
about dashboard product. And since in our case,
it's a homepage, we go with about product. Okay,
so our initial setup works somewhat Alright, where
your all's are matching, whatever we set up there
with nested routes, but the problem is the result.
We keep seeing all the time The homepage. So how
we can fix that and how we can also set up a
shared layout? Well, we need to go to the parent,
in our case, home and import outlet, the
outlet component. And then we just need to
display this ultimate component. Whatever
we'll set up around this outlet component
is going to be the shared layout across the
pages that are nested inside of the parent.
And then the actual page content will
be displayed here. In the output of one,
I think it's going to make a little bit more sense
if we set it up. And that way, you're right away,
see what I'm talking about. So let me go to home
a Jas, we want to grab this outlet component. And
the position is really up to you. Again,
you'll see once we add navbar, that of course,
however you set up this return, that is going to
be how your shared layout is going to look like.
Now I'm not going to keep this link, I think
we're good to go. So I'm gonna go with outlet.
And now, once I save, actually, I see this
homepage. So at the moment, this will be
shared all across the pages. But I nicely also see
the about page. And if I'm going to navigate to a
product, same deal, I still see this homepage. So
this one is shared all across these nested pages.
Also, I see the actual content from the product
page. So now we can put two and two together.
If this is shared all across the nested
pages. Why don't we set up the navbar.
Add some links. And as a result, we'll be able
to navigate from page to page from home to about
until the product now notes up, we need
to go with new components. So I'll set up
the components folder. And in there, I'll create
navbar J S. And we want to import a link one.
And then let's set up the nav, then let's
import that in home J S and again, whatever,
return your set up over here. That's how all those
pages will be displayed. So if you do the side,
let's say underneath the section to set up a
footer, you can definitely do so again, this
is going to be that shared layout all across the
pages. And don't worry, the homepage, the actual
parent is going to look somewhat funky.
We'll work on that one next. So first,
let's worry about Napa. And I want to do
that by navigating here. Please don't set
this one up on the finals. Because it's already
there, we have the components. So in the source,
I want to create actually not a new file, I
want to create a new folder component. And this,
of course also showcases that, of course, like
I said, all of the components in the pages,
we can use other components because they're just
good all the regular components. I'll set up
navbar je s now there's going to be one more file
because I'll show you the active link as well. But
let's not worry about it right now. I'm using this
extension to create my component, this is going
to be number like I said, I do want to get the
link. So let me close the sidebar here. I'll say
link from and then we're looking for
React Router DOM. And then we want to go
with a nav now I did add a little bit of styling
and CSS. That's well add here class name, nav bar,
and then we're just want to set up the links.
Now I will set up links for about products,
and homepage. But we might add one more for login
one little bit later. So let's go here with Link
to this is going to be through the homepage.
And then let's add a text. Let's copy and paste.
Now this one will be through about page again,
whatever pages you have. So in our case, we have
about and products as well as the home page. Let's
set up about let's set up all of your products.
And now we want to navigate to the home one
and import that navbar. So let's go with import
nav bar. And basically, you're
gonna get the component.
Like I keep saying whatever structure we will
set up over here is going to be the result
in the browser show. I don't want to keep this
section right now as it is. Instead I'm going to
go with React fragments since we need to return
one element. Then I'll play In navbar, on top,
after that, I will remove this homepage.
And then let me bring this section up.
So I'll display the navbar. Mike. So with
these links, and in here in the section,
I will have that outlet, basically, whatever
we have inside of the page. So whatever we
have in the amount in the product, essentially
all the pages that we have nested as a result,
notice, not only I display the contents of the
about page or the Products page, but we also have
the number. So if you want to add the footer,
go ahead. Most likely, you'll want to do that
beneath the section. With this in place, now we
can set up the index page, because at the moment,
if we navigate here, nothing is displayed.
So let's fix that in next video. Alright,
so our functionality is almost complete. The only
thing that's missing is the content in homepage.
First, let's understand why that is happening in
the app. Jas, we have nicely nested the routes.
For the parent, we have the home. And inside of
the home, we have the outlet. And there we display
product about as well as the error page, something
that I actually forgot to add last video. So if
I'm gonna go with Hello, notice, again, we'll
still have that mesh layout, the shared one with
the navbar and all that. And in here, we display
the content. But when it comes to actual homepage,
well, we don't have any specific content here.
That's why we render pretty much nothing, we just
have the number. And technically, if you want
you can add that heading to or whatever content
you want. But just keep in mind that that will
be shared all across the components, basically
the pages we have nested. So what is the solution?
Well, the solution is to set up index route. And
here I just added some text from the React Router
docs, you can definitely read it through but I
think it's going to be faster if I just showcase
the syntax. So if we have these nested routes,
for the main one for the parent, we can set up
the index route. And it has a special syntax.
Whenever we go route, then we pass in the
Prop by the name of index. And this will
always always always match whatever we have here
for the parent path. So if this is going to be
dashboard, that yes, this index is going to match
the dashboard. However, since in our case, we have
home we have home. And then again the same deal,
we go with element. Now the gotcha here is that
we still want to set up some kind of shared
layout. Correct. And therefore we'll have to
create a new component in that new component,
and basically take whatever we have right now
in the home one. And we'll add that one
as a shared layout in here as an element.
So whatever we have right now in the home, we'll
create a new component, we'll call the share
layout. So now always share this layout all across
these pages, but then the home one will have its
own content. Hopefully this makes sense. So now
let me save this. And let me first go to a pages,
then we want to create a new one. And I'm going to
call this shared layout. As always, you can call
this shake and bake doesn't really matter. Let's
grab the home one. And you know, also, as we will
be setting this up, we're going to remove that
section because each of them have already that
section with a class name of section. So that is
an overkill. So let me navigate to shared layout,
copy and paste. Now let me remove this section,
we don't need it. So now we have only two things.
We have layout, which will have the page
content, whatever is the page, the homepage,
the about page, the product page, and also
whatever we want to put around it. So in my case,
that is just the number. And once we have this one
in place, let's navigate to app. Jas. We want to
set up that shared layout first. So let's say he
shared layout. Yep, of course it breaks. So let
me copy and paste. I'll say here shared layout.
And now we just need to work on that index page.
So if we want to set up a page that
will match the parent. In this nested
URL structure we go route Then index, and then
we're passing the element. So in this case,
you want to go with home. And now we need to
navigate. And first of all, we need to close it
here, when we want to navigate to the home one.
And since the moment I'm displaying the navbar,
we want to remove some stuff where I think I will
remove both the Lincoln outlet, I don't think
we'll need it, since we already have the knob. But
anyway, and then we're just need to come up with
whatever we want to render. So I don't want the
outlet. I don't want to navbar I just want to go
with my good old heading to and I'll say homepage.
And, yes, we can also remove the second lag. I
said, Yes, I purposely did this the long way to
kind of showcase how we get to that shared layout
and what issues we're going to get along the way.
So yes, there was a little bit of refactoring. The
good news is that check out through our result, we
have homepage, which displays home and about one
product. And if we have some kind of page that
doesn't exist, let's say product. And hello,
when we display homepage, and we nicely
navigate back. So hopefully, this is clear,
where if we want to set up this shared layout,
first, we need to come up with the parent in
our case that is index. But again, I showed you
example, with dashboard, whatever you type over
here, that's going to be the parent, then most
likely, you will come up with some kind of shared
layout. So what you want to share across those
pages, and as far as the parent, you'll set up
the index. So that will be the content only for
the actual index. And then rest of the pages.
And remember, we need to use outlet to render
those results. All right. Before we start working
with URL parameters, let's also see how we can set
up active links. And effectively what that means
is that once we're on the page, this link will
have specific styling, whatever we want to set up.
And in order to do that, I will create a new file,
just so typical setup stays for your reference.
And instead of link, we want to grab the nav
link. Now what's special about the novel link
is the fact that in style, and also in the
class name, we can pass in the function
where there's a property by the name of is
active. Again, this is provided right away
by React Router, a man based on that value, we
can set up some type of styling. Again, this is
the straight up inline CSS approach. But we
can also do that with classes. And of course,
we'll take a look at both examples. Let's
start working on the main setup first,
where in the components let's create styled
navbar. And again, the reason why I'm setting
up a separate file is just so you have right
away a reference for the basic setup. Let's
copy and paste again, we're looking for nav link
instead. And let's change these suckers as well.
So we're looking for nav link. For now let's not
do anything, let's not add any kind of logic,
we simply want to navigate to Baba Baba app, Jas,
or I'm sorry, what app js shared layout, my bad.
And I'll copy and paste. And I'll just say, shared
layout shared, or I'm sorry, not shared layout.
For some reason, I'm totally tripping there.
So styled and navbar. Of course, my apologies.
And for some reason, I didn't change this one
as well, instead of typical navbar. Let's go
here with styled number. And once we save, we
will right away notice that our active link
gets different styling. And first, let's just
quickly cover why is that happening? And second,
we'll take a look at the code that controls that.
So first, why is that happening? Well, again,
by default, if we use that Novolin,
the React router by default, even
without us doing anything adds this class of
active to it. If you take a look at index CSS,
and more specifically, if you just keep on
scrolling somewhere on the Navbar you'll find this
active class. So if you just set up an active
class, if you use network, the class will be
automatically added. As a result, you'll get the
styles. So now let's see how we can control that
code a little bit more. First of all, let me
close all my files and all that here. So let
me start from scratch. I think it's getting
quite busy. Let's just take a look at how
we can add good old regular CSS to it. So I'm
in the style number, then we want to go with
style over here, and I'm not going to add to all
of them, but I will showcase for the home one.
So I'm gonna go with style, I want to
go with interpolation. And like I said,
we want to pass here, the function, this function,
the value and all that is provided by React
Router DOM. Now, keep in mind, this is not just
good old parameter here. So don't say is active,
we need to specifically look for objects and then
is active. That's how we can properly access that.
And then since we're setting up here, inline
styles, we can just use a ternary operator,
where we go with returns. So what are we returning
this object will be applied to this link.
And more specifically, I want to look for the
color. And then I want to check is active. So
what is the value. So if it is true, I want to
add color red. And if it's not, then I want to
go with gray. Please keep in mind that we can
set up whatever functionality you want over here,
I'm just going for straight up color. Of course,
if you prefer setting up your CSS in line, you can
add whatever the properties with values you want.
And now check it out. If we navigate to home page,
the style will be red. So the color of the link
was going to be red. And yes, if we add this to
the rest of the links, it's also going to work,
I already set up the reference for your here.
So in my case, in the style nine bar,
I'll just showcase the class approach,
since in my opinion, that's probably is going
to be something you will use more often. So if
you ever need this reference, it's available in
the readme. So let me remove this style here.
And now instead of style, I'm gonna go with class
name. And if we take a look at the CSS, you'll
notice that not only I have the active one, I also
have some general style for the link. And yes,
of course, like I keep repeating, you
would normally add more code over here.
So instead of just relying on the active one, I'll
say, All right, what is the value for is active.
If it's true, then I want to add link class,
as well as the actor one. Basically, this is
where I'll have more styles normally. And if it's
not, then just going to be link class, which just
gives those general stuff. So let's try this one
out, where again, we are going forward a function
in the function, we're looking for the object, and
then we go with E is active. And then let's set up
that ternary operator, where we want to go with is
active and you're not thinking in this case, I'm
just gonna go with implicit return, so is active,
if it's the case, then I'm gonna go with Link
and active. And then if it's not, then I'm just
gonna go with link one, I do want to grab this
entire thing. So copy, hopefully, there are
no bugs there. And then let's just set up on
all of these ones, let's save, this is going to
be our default setup. And then once we click,
now, of course, we get that active class, as well.
And as you saw, there's multiple ways that we can
set up. If you just an act of class, it will
be added by default that now. So technically,
you don't need to do anything. But most likely,
you will set up the class approach. Also, keep in
mind that, of course, you do have this inline CSS
option as well. Most importantly, mavlink, then
the function, then object in the object, you have
these actor, and then you can use this value to
set up your logic. Alright, and now let's see how
we can read URL parameters. And as a result, we'll
have some dynamic pages. For this, I just want
you to imagine a product page where we display a
bunch of products. And then once we click on that
one specific product, we display it in a separate
page. However, here's the key. I don't want to set
up a separate page for every product that I have.
It makes more sense for me to set up one
page, which is going to act as a placeholder.
And then I'll just get the data that I need
to display. So that way I can use the same
page for example 4000 products or 3000. On
hopefully you see where I'm going with it.
And in order to set up your URL parameters, you
want to go with this colon, and then whatever the
parameter name, call this I can bake all
this vegan food truck in my cache, since
will display product, I just thought is going to
make more sense if I'm going to go with colon,
and then product ID. But this name is
really up to you. Now, as far as this URL,
this can be straight up like so, where we go
with colon and product ID, this can be product
stats, and then product ID. Again,
this part is really up to you.
I just thought that going with product, and
then product IV is going to make more sense.
Before we begin, I also want to quickly mention
that yes, you can set up that nested structure,
like we did over here, for a product and product
ID as well. I just went with this setup for two
reasons. First, I really, really, really want to
focus on the URL params. And I think it's gonna
be better if we use this setup. For that way,
it's easier for us, we don't need to do this
whole song and dance. And second, I also want to
showcase that if you don't have the shared layout,
which in this case, we want, you don't always
have to use that approach. You can also use
this approach as well, where you go with whatever
is the main URL. And then in here, specifically,
we go with this dynamic option. Hopefully that
is clear. So first, let's navigate right now
to app Jas and get that single product. So if
we take a look at the pages, there is already a
single product, there's just a heading two. So why
don't we in the app js, first of all, set it up,
and I'll do that right after the product. So
let's go with route event path, then we'll go
with a product and that product ID. And you'll
see that it is essentially a property. So again,
we can name it whatever we want. So go with colon
product, ID and then what is going to be the
placeholder, well, we want to go with LM meant.
And then we want to go with that single product,
which hopefully is going to work but doesn't look
like it. So that's why sometimes this auto import
is annoying, because it doesn't work. So let
me save this. And yes, of course I have there.
So let me go here with import, and then single,
single product like so. And that is coming from.
And we're looking in the pages, I believe,
right. And then we have single product.
So not everything works, we have that
similar product. And now if we go to URL,
if we just type whatever gibberish we
want. So eventually, there's going to be
actual data, because they already prepared
for you. But I'd say if we type 123,
we have single product. If we type in a three
through three, we'll also get that single product.
So that's the placeholder we're going to use.
So now let's navigate to the single product. And
let's take a look how we can access it. So this
is the setup, where we go with that colon and then
whatever is going to be the parameter names or
macros product ID. Now, if we need to access it,
we need to get the hook from React Router DOM.
So use, use params. And we'll also get the link.
And then we want to invoke that hook. And notice
how this name now needs to match whatever we have
over here. So as long as they match, you'll be in
good shape. And then for timing legends displayed.
And let's navigate back to the main product page.
So let's set this one up. Where I don't think I'll
need styled navbar anymore. But I do want to
navigate to single product. Like I said, we're
going to be looking for two things, we're gonna
get the link first. And also we want to get that
hook use parameter, which is going to access those
parameters in the URL when all that is coming from
react. Yep, that's not correct. We need
to go with import my apologies, not const.
So let's go with React Router Dom, then as far as
the return, first we want to grab that product ID.
And you know, as a side note, why don't we do
this? Why don't we just log the sucker? So let's
say you're used params. And you'll clearly see,
what am I talking about? So let's invoke this. And
then let's navigate to the console and check it
out. We have the object. What do you know? We have
product ID 333. So you fill changes around 123.
And of course that value will be also 123. So now
we want to pull this out from the use params from
the object so let's go with product. And then Id
Now that is equal to use params. Let's invoke
it. And like I said, let's set up that link back
to the product, push if you want to navigate
also back home. But my guess it's going to be
back to the products back product. Where we have
right now the single product for time being let's
go with adding four. And let's display the ID.
So let's say here, product, and then it would
save it and check it out. Now we have 123.
Again, if we'll change this around to 4567,
this is going to be the value show. Next video,
we'll iterate over the products that I provided
in I believe data address, we'll run them all of
them in the Products page. And then from there,
we'll set up a single product page as well. All
right, and once we have the single product page
in place, now in the products J S, let's iterate
over the products that are coming from the beta.
And then for every item, I want to return an
article will have to use the key since of course,
this is react. And then I want to access product
name, as well as product ID, which I'll pass into
this link. And notice the URL. Again, this needs
to match whatever we have in app J S. Since in
the app J S, we have products and product ID, this
is where we dynamically pass in the ID property,
which is going to be in every product. Once we
set this one up, then in the single product,
we'll use that ID. And instead of rendering it on
the screen, like we have right now, basically pull
out that one specific product, then we'll get
the image and name. And then we'll display it.
Now before we continue with me right away
say that, yes, normally we'll get this
data from the API or database or whatever.
But since I want to keep this nice and cute,
that's why I'm prepared this data Jas,
which essentially is just an array
of products, each product has the ID. So this
is something else see over here in Euro name,
as well as the image, which is just an
external URL. So these images are stored
on a cloud somewhere. So that way, we don't need
to bother with the local image setup. So first,
let's go to a product js. And we want to
get the data. Now if you want, of course,
you can log it, but I'm just gonna assume that
it's there. And also, we want to get the link,
because each and every product will be
wrapped in a link. So React Router Dom,
then off the bat, let's go import that product
from. Like I said, we're looking forward to data.
Jas. As far as they return, it looks like for
some reason, I set it up as a React fragment.
My bad, let me just remove, we'll have section
here, we'll have product. And then right after
that, we want to go div with a class of product.
So then there's little bit of styling over there.
Let's go with product map or mapping over. And
then as far as the return, let's go for product.
Again, if you want to log it, you can definitely
do so in my case, I know that, essentially, there
is going to be all those properties. So I want
to return article, I do want to add right away
a key. And I'll just say here, product ID, then
I also want to go with heading five, and I'll say
product name. And also we want to set up that
link. Now, I believe previously, I mentioned
that we'll wrap it, my apologies. We'll just set
up the link here. So let's go here with link to
Now remember, this is dynamic. So now, we are not
passing this manually 456 Or seven, we actually
go with product, bath and then that dynamic
Id rather so let's go with template string,
then product, and forward slash and now let's
access that sucker. Let's say product, then ID
and then set it with let's just
say more info. Let's save it.
This is that single product, so we won't see
anything. But if we navigate back, check it out.
Now we have a list of products title, as well
as the link. So this is going to be more info.
Now notice we have this unique ID in two places.
We have it over here. And we also render it.
So now we just need to add some code to single
product. Well first, I'll grab it okay. as good,
but I also want to get the product from there
right from the data product from that data. Very
good. Like I keep saying, normally this is going
to happen with some kind of fetch request from the
API and all that, but not in this case. So I want
to get the single product. And that is going to be
with products, then use Find. And now we'll just
say, get me the product whose ID matches the
product product here, and then return a product
ID equals to product id like so. So product.id
equals to product that beautiful, then let's pull
out image, nine, we don't need the ID anymore.
And then let's set it up in our return, we're
first we're gonna go with a heading five, I guess.
And instead of product ID, I want to
display the name, and then right above it,
or below it or whatever. Just go with IMG source
mount will be equal to that external image.
So let's set up the image over here. If you
want, we can also set up the alternative.
Let's close the image. And as a result, we
get the single product. And like I said, Now
consider 1000 products, so we can render them
in the product page. And then for each product,
there's going to be a single product page,
essentially, which act as a placeholder will
fetch some data about that one specific product.
And we'll render that in the single product page.
And now let's see how we can navigate around
our project programmatically, ie in our case,
that is going to be once we submit the form.
And also, let's see how we can restrict access
to certain routes. Before we begin, though, please
keep in mind that normally, we will use context
to store our user value. In this
case, I just didn't see the point of
setting up the entire boilerplate. And we want to
start in the app J S, wherever you want to set up
user state value with your state, an initial
value will be known. Then we want to import
two more pages, we want to import the login
page, as well as the dashboard one, again,
the boilerplate placeholders are already there.
And then in the login one, we want to pass in the
function, the one that sets up the user in the
dashboard, we want to pass in the actual user.
So let's start in the app js, where we want to
get the use state from react or import use state
that is coming from react. And let's set up that
state value. So in here, let's go with const.
User Set user that is equal to use state. Let's
pass in and then let's grab both of those pages.
So we're talking about the dashboard, as well
as the login one. Now dashboard doesn't have
anything, pretty much the same boilerplate and
login has a little bit more, and I'll cover that
in a second. Now, since my auto imports were
not particularly successful, let's try it here,
where I'm gonna go with the dashboard, dashboard.
And again, it's not working. So know what's
up with that. So let's go with pages. Yvonne,
let's access the dashboard on copy and paste.
This case, let's delete. Let's just go with login.
And right after that single product, first of all,
I'll make my browser bigger here, I want to go
above the arrow one. Let's set up that route,
the login one, so path will be login.
And then we want to go with element.
And let's pass in the login one. And then inside
of the login element, let's also pass in set user
is equal to set user. So now we're passing in
this function. Now we do want to close this one,
meaning the route. So at service, learn, we'll
copy and paste. This is going to be dashboard
dashboard. And the components will be dashboard
as well. And set of set user go to User
so user is equal to user let's save this. Now
let's navigate to the login one and you're not
actually I also want to add the link to the login
one so not to dashboard but to the login one.
And if you remember that was in the style number
two So let's navigate here. And let's add one more
link. Let's copy and paste, this is not going to
go to product, this is going to go to login. And
then also the text will be login. Let's save
it, we have the login. Once we navigate here,
we notice that we have the form, which is
awesome. So now let's navigate to the page.
And we'll take a look at what we have and what
changes we need to add. So I important you state
I have two states values have name and email and
I right away have the handle submit where we have
prevent default, pretty much basic setup. Also,
both of them are set up as controlled inputs. So
they're tied to the state value. So as you start
typing, you basically will have both of the values
over there. Now if you want to test this out,
let's go with log and then say name, and email,
and pretty typical setup. So I'm gonna go here
with John, John gmail.com. And once we log,
check this out, we have both of the values. So
here's what we want to do. In the login one,
we want to check whether both values are there. If
there they are, first, we want to set the user. So
this one was coming from the app Jas and yes, I
purposely went here the long route. And then we
want to get us navigate from React Router DOM.
And we want to navigate programmatically to a
dashboard. So notice, in this case, not
happening once we're clicking on a link,
or Novolin. In this case, we'll navigate there
using navigate. And in order to invoke that we
get to use navigate, we invoke it, this is going
to be equal to navigate. And then in here, we
just provide where we want to navigate. And then
in the dashboard, since we can access the user,
I just want to say hello, and then the user
name. Now we are using optional chaining,
because remember, initially, it's going
to be no. So let's try to set this one up.
Where in the login, first let's grab that navigate
us navigate that is coming from React Router Dom,
then I already have the console log.
Okay, beautiful. Let me remove it.
And in here, above the house submit,
let's set up that navigate. So now we are
equal to use navigate, let's invoke that.
And then we're gonna go with if condition.
So if there is no name, or there is no email, so
if one of them is missing, then we want to return.
And yes, that is the check that I'm going
to set up right now. So there's going to be
no error messages, nothing like that. I just
want to check whether one of them is empty.
If one of them is empty, we'll simply return.
Now, if both of them are provided, we'll go
set user. Now we just want to grab it from the
params. So let's set up here, set user. Again,
this is coming from the app jet, like So first,
we want to invoke it, we want to go set user,
let's pass in the name equals the name and email
equals email. If you want to shorten this up,
of course, you can definitely do so. And then
let's go with navigate. And where we want to go,
we want to go to forward slash dashboard. Let's
save this one right now. Let's try to do that
with only John. So if I just provide one
value, notice I can undo anything. Or if I go
John and gmail.com will notice that we'll nicely
navigate to the dashboard one. And in dashboard,
I just want to display the name. The way we
set it up. If we take a look at the dashboard,
we just want to grab the user since that is
what we're passing in the app js again. More
specifically, I'll look for name however, there
is going to be optional chaining, since initially,
it's going to be no. So let me now get right
now to the dashboard one, let me grab the user.
And then once we destructured where we have
the heading for instead, I'll say hello.
And let's just access the user name, like I said
optional chaining. And then let's go for name once
we save we have Hello John. So if we'll navigate
to a login and we'll go with Peter instead
and peter@gmail.com First, we'll programmatically
navigate once we submit the form using the US
navigate which we imported, then invoke that
and we just passing the path, the dashboard one.
In the Dashboard page, we actually display the
name of the user which in this case is better.
Alright, and now let's see how we can restrict
access to certain route and first in the pages
We'll have to create that component. So in
this case is going to be protected route.
And then in the app js, you want to wrap whatever
page you want to restrict access to, in that
protected route. So yes, in the element, you'll
have to go to protected route. And then whatever
page you want to render, so automatically, this
page will be restricted. So let's start here in
the pages, let's set up a new file. I'll
call this protected route. For time being,
it doesn't really matter what we display here,
since the logic is going to change anyway. And
once we have the file ready to go, let's navigate
back to app J. S, we want to go with protected
route. And since I don't want to restrict access
to the dashboard, now I want to wrap the dashboard
with a protected route. I'll set it up as
self closing. Let's go here with protected
route. Like I said, normally will pass in
the user using use context. Our in this case,
since it's right away in the app js, I just go
with user equals to user since we'll need to
check it. And if the user exists, only then
will display the dashboard. So now notice,
even though technically URL says dashboard, we're
displaying this protected route, because now we're
wrapping dashboard with protected route. So up
next, let's set up the functionality. Where in
the protected route, we want to import,
navigate component from React Router DOM.
And then we want access to things.
We want to access the children.
So this is going to be that dashboard page, or
whatever page we place in that protected route,
and also a user. And then we'll check if the user
doesn't exist, we want to use navigate component.
And we'll just say where we want to
navigate. However, if everything is correct,
we'll return children, in our case is going
to be our dashboard. So let's go to protected
route. And first, let's grab that
navigate. So I'm gonna go here with import,
then navigate. So navigate component from
React Router Dom, very much access both props,
so children's prop, so children, and then also
user. And let's set up that logic where if there
is no user, then we want to go with return and
navigate to I'm just going to go to homepage.
Please keep in mind, we can navigate wherever
we want. And then if everything is correct,
then we'll just return children. So with this in
place, what's going to happen once we refresh,
we'll have homepage. If let's say we try to
somehow manually get to the dashboard, the axis
will be restricted. Notice how we navigate back
why? Well, because there is no user. So only if
we go to a login one, add that user my case,
John john@gmail.com, then we'll be successful.
And we'll navigate through a dashboard. The split.
Again, I guess the biggest gotcha is the fact that
in the app js where you render the pages, you do
need to wrap it, you need to wrap whichever page
you want to restrict access to in the protected
route component. Beautiful. At the very end,
I just want to set up of the product and product
ID as a nested route. And this is the case where
if you want to challenge yourself, you can
stop the video and try doing it yourself.
So basically, whatever we have right now, here
with a homepage, where we nested rest of the
route. I also want to do the same thing with a
product where we want to place a product ID inside
of the product, we do want to set up the index
one, as well as some shared layout. So again,
if you want to try doing that for yourself,
stop the video, try to solve this puzzle again.
Basically, the setup is exactly the same, you'll
probably want to use a different shared component.
That's it. So let's start here by setting
up that component. So I'm gonna go here with
shared product and layout. I know it's somewhat
long name, but we'll deal with up, then let's
grab quickly to code over here, since I don't
want to waste my time on imports and all that.
So I have here link, I don't think I'll need that.
What I want is outlet, I won't need the navbar.
And as far as the shared layout, well, there's
not really much that I want to add over here.
And guess I'm just gonna take a look at the
products one. So in here, I just have heading
two. So let's do it this way where we'll go with
heading to go with products. We'll keep that one.
And we won't need the import for the
style bar as well learn let's go back
to our app J Yes, we want to grab that
long component. So let's say here import,
shared, shared, and it was product product
layout, J S. So that is coming from the
pages, I believe. All right. So shared product
layout. Let's close this, before we continue
in the product j s, we can just remove
the heading to let's set up the entire
logic here, where first we want to go with the
route, the path will be products correct. So
we're gonna go here with products. Now as far as
the element, we'll go with that shared product
layout. Let's close this one. And then in
here, let's set up both of these routes. Now
we can remove the path and just say index. And
for this sucker, just going to be product ID.
And once we save, I'll make this one bigger.
Now, as you can see, the result did not change.
So the functionality is exactly the same. The only
difference is that now again, we're using this
nested routes approach, where we have the parent.
We have the shared layout by the way, this is
a tiny typo here. So shared layout.
And this is going to be our index page,
which is our product page. And we'll also have
a single product page. I'm not sure that for
React Router six tutorial Hopefully everyone
enjoyed it. And I'll see you in the next videos.